if i were running for political office
right now what i would be focused on
is letting the american people know how
i can best serve them uh you know that
that's really all that matters and i
think uh for those who are running for
office and frankly for voters um
all they want is solutions you know
there's so much uh partisanship and
there's so much hey finger-pointing it's
their fault and it's their fault uh if
you're running for office at any level
um you know when i ran for city council
in hawaii and state house and and for
congress and for president frankly uh i
wasn't focused on what all of these
other people or candidates were doing i
was focused on addressing um the
challenges that people across this
country are facing and and offering um
to serve them and to to uh to to try to
address those challenges and i think
that's the most important thing any
candidate can and should be focused on
rather than uh what anyone else is doing
it is unfortunate that we have leaders
in in great positions of power and
influence
who are intentionally choosing not to
reach out to voters across the country
uh to people across the country
regardless of you know what their
political affiliation may be regardless
of what cable news channel they may
watch
it's a big problem that we have leaders
who are choosing to
uh essentially leave out and ignore uh
you know hundreds of millions of people
in this country simply because um they
may not agree with them on all issues
uh you know regardless of your party
it's important that we have leaders who
are there to serve all americans because
that's exactly what the job description
says not just people of your own party
and in order to bridge that divide
you've got to be willing to listen
you've got to be willing to try to
understand a different perspective and
then of course see how we can how we can
work together as americans to solve the
problems and serve the best interests of
the american people in our country every
election is an opportunity for voters
across the country
to be able to
keep those in office they have
confidence in and fire those that they
don't no politician should take their
job for granted um
this is how our democracy was intended
we've got a lot to do to be able to
improve
the integrity of our elections and
making sure that when people go and cast
their vote they have the confidence that
their vote will be counted
it is incumbent upon all of us as voters
to be engaged in this process and not be
afraid to fire those who are failing to
do their job uh people in washington
work for us they work for voters we are
the ones who have the power to be able
to hire and fire those who have the best
interests of the american people in our
country at heart and so for those who
are dissatisfied with the direction of
our country who are dissatisfied with
the leadership that we have well these
elections that we have coming up in just
a few months both primaries and general
elections and of course the election
2024 is our opportunity to have our
voice heard